[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans cette édition
spéciale préparé par la rédaction de tv
78 sommes le jeudi 10 mars voici les
titres
le sommet européen s'est ouvert
aujourd'hui au château de versailles
emmanuel macron réunit les chefs d'état
et de gouvernement de l'union européenne
jusqu'à vendredi quels sont les enjeux
du rendez vous en plein contexte de la
guerre en ukraine éléments de réponse
avec nos invités au coeur de l'événement
la ville de versailles et son château
qui seront au centre de l'attention la
vie des habitants et quelque peu
bouleversé et pendant deux jours nous
vous emmènerons aussi dans les coulisses
du sommet avec un dispositif de sécurité
conséquent et plus de 500 journalistes
accrédités
enfin ce n'est pas une première dans la
cité royale le château a été souvent
dans l'histoire un lieu symbolique de la
diplomatie française et européenne
retour sur les précédents dans cette
édition
toujours dans l'histoire nous verrons a
que les thématiques de l'indépendance
énergétique et aussi de l'europe de la
défense ne sont pas nouvelles et été
évoqué même au fondement de l'europe et
ce sera tout à l'heure
mais direction tout de suite le château
de versailles où se tient le sommet
européen pour retrouver nicolas landry
de la rédaction de tv 78 bon soir
nicolas
et la séance plénière d'ouverture s'est
ouverte il ya quelques minutes puisque
elle a démarré à partir de 17h30 oui
c'est ce que même un peu plus longtemps
puisque emmanuel macron a tenu une
conférence de presse juste sur la cour
du marbre du château de versailles était
16h45 quand émue elle est arrivée au
château de versailles est suivi de près
par les 26 chefs d'état et de
gouvernement des pays membres de l'union
européenne nous avons véritablement
assisté à un ballet de véhicules avec
des petits drapeaux des états européens
pour les reconnaître créant même un
bouchon sur la place d'armes devant le
château de versailles voilà pour la
forme sur le fond ce sommet européen eba
a débuté comme vous l'avez dit avec
cette session plénière il a quelques
minutes les dirigeants européens bon
planché sur plusieurs enjeux sur fond de
toile sur toile de fond pardon de
l'invasion de l'ukraine par la russie
d'abord il sera question de l'autonomie
énergétique et alimentaire vis-à-vis de
la russie et de l'union européenne
ensuite les dirigeants européens vont
discuter aussi de l'europe de la défense
un sujet qui a longtemps était débattu
entre les états membres et il faudra
savoir s'il faut aller plus loin dans ce
contexte de guerre enfin la france
poussent pour un nouveau plan
d'investissement après le plan de
relance économique historique décidée en
2020 bref la question centrale ce sera
de savoir s'il faut aller plus loin sur
la souveraineté européenne
réponse demain après midi avec les
conclusions de ce sommet européen à
versailles merci nicolas et la connexion
s'est totalement rétabli on vous
entendez en tout cas très bien pour ce
point d'information merci beaucoup merci
aussi à michael et demi d'euros qui est
avec vous un surplace au château de
versailles pour les moyens techniques et
pour parler de ce sommet européen deux
premiers invités dans cette édition
spéciale martha de sea dragon soir
bonsoir sénatrice des yvelines sénatrice
les républicains vous êtes aussi la
secrétaire de la commission des affaires
étrangères des affaires européennes au
sénat voilà affaires européennes la
précision est donnée et je préciser
quand vous êtes la présidente de la
maison europe des yvelines qui est
installée à saint germain en laye avec
nous en visioconférence également
vincent couronne bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes docteur en droit public enseignant
chercheur à l'université versailles
saint quentin et fondateur à des
surligneurs c'est un groupe de juristes
universitaires qui relève les faits que
news et les explique merci à tous les
deux d'être avec nous on le disait un
sommet qui s'ouvre dans ce contexte en
plein contexte de la guerre en ukraine
et depuis le début du conflit on entend
beaucoup parler d'union européenne de
ces différentes institutions mais aussi
de conseil de l'europe qui sont des
choses totalement différentes difficile
d'y voir clair vincent couronne
finalement dans ce conflit on a
l'impression que c'est plusieurs europe
qui sont imbriqués qui sont concernés
oui effectivement mais c'est tout là la
particularité presque je pourrais dire
aussi la richesse du continent européen
c'est qu'il y à l'union européenne qui
est cette union qu'on connaît bien mais
et économie politique etc mais il ya
aussi le conseil de l'europe dont fait
partie du crem ce conseil de l'europe
qui est là pour protéger la paix les
droits de l'homme
et la russie aussi fait partie même si
elle vient effectivement de d'annoncer
vouloir en sortir du conseil de l'europe
met donc du coup voilà il ya plusieurs
europe et puis on peut pas ne pas citer
aussi mais on en reparlera de l'otan qui
est une organisation dans laquelle 21,1
membres sont aussi membres de l'union
européenne et qui est un des éléments
centraux de la défense européenne donc
c'est que le continent européen est un
continent d'imbrication d'organisations
internationales dans lesquelles il y a
il n'ya pas certains états je précise
juste qu'on entendait henri malot ce qui
est président de l'association jean
monnet qui interviendra un peu plus tard
dans cette édition spéciale alors matmar
talent de cédric là pour ce sommet qui
se déroule à versailles on parle bien de
l'union européenne qui est réunie par
emmanuel macron puisque on le rappelle
emmanuel macron et la france a pris la
présidence tournante du conseil de
l'union européenne depuis le 1er janvier
là encore pour l'union européenne à
différentes institutions c'est difficile
de s'y retrouver
c'est vrai que c'est parfois un petit
peu compliqué pour le commun des mortels
de s'y retrouver alors nous avons c'est
vrai qu'on parle très couramment de la
commission de la commission l'europe qui
en réalité l'organe législatif l'organe
opérationnel en réalité un pas
législatives et opérationnels
véritablement de l'europe nous avons
aussi le parlement qui est pour le coup
un organe législatif puisque les
parlementaires nos eurodéputés sièges au
parlement donc de l'europe et nous avons
cela a été évoqué nous avons le conseil
mais nous avons aussi cette présidence
tournante qui est celle des du conseil
de l'union européenne qui est celle des
présidents des états en fait puisque
nous avons aussi le conseil des
ministres des différents états qui selon
les thématiques abordées se réunissent
de manière à pouvoir avancer sur un
certain nombre de sujets dans
aujourd'hui nous sommes pleinement au
coeur de la présidence française de
l'union européenne puisque c'est la
france qui du 1er janvier jusqu'au
jusqu'au 1er juillet assurera donc c'est
présidence et pour laquelle donc tous
ces chefs d'état sont réunis à
versailles aujourd'hui et demain voilà
pour ce petit point pédagogique ça va
nous aider à y voir plus clair pour
aborder est la suite des thématiques une
précision importante des gens alors
rendez vous était déjà prévu la
thématique initial était un nouveau
modèle de croissance pour l'europe mais
forcément au vu du contexte de cette
guerre en ukraine l'ordre du jour a été
bouleversée avec donc plusieurs
thématiques qui ont été évoqués il ya un
instant par nicolas landry en premier
lieu on parlera de d'europe de la
défense ou de la défense européenne et
les deux termes sont utilisés alors
c'est une première déjà dans l'histoire
de l'union européenne le déblocage de
450 millions d'euros pour fournir du
matériel létale à l'armée ukrainienne on
parlait avant sans couronne de l'otan
justement en dehors de l'otan et de
cette alliance atlantique ses 30 membres
est-ce que la défense européenne existe
voilà réponse elle est assez clair non
il n'y a pas aujourd'hui 2 ray défense
européenne on dit souvent que la défense
européenne en réalité même si en france
on a du mal à l'entendre c'est l'otan la
véritable défense militaire du
territoire de l'union européenne en
revanche il existe déjà des initiatives
des politiques qui ont été mises en
oeuvre dans le cadre de la politique
européenne de défense on peut citer par
exemple les groupements tactiques qui
sont des des bataillons de 1500 soldats
européens prêts à intervenir
militairement mais qui n'ont jamais été
utilisés alors on a on a eu aussi par
exemple l'intervention des européens au
mali dans le cadre de la force nakba
mais là c'était simplement quelques
états membres qui intervenait en dehors
de la politique européenne de défense
pour soutenir des français de
l'opération barkan et c'était une petite
mission on va le dire un mille hommes
seulement sans engagement véritablement
offensif la l'ukraine change pas mal les
choses parce que désormais l'union
européenne va piocher elle pioche comme
vous venez de le dire dans une enveloppe
globale de 5 milliards d'euros n'est pas
utilisée uniquement 450 millions pour
moment pour financer la livraison
d'armes à l'ukraine et puis le conseil
européen qui s'ouvre ce soir est bien
l'objectif en tout cas un des espoirs de
pas mal d'états membres c'est qu' il y
ait plus investissements dans les
projets de défense mais en donc plus
d'argent pour pour le pour le militaire
mais pour l'armement notamment en
revanche pas de modification
institutionnelle c'est à dire qu'on va
on va pas passer à des décisions à la
majorité plutôt qu'à l'unanimité ce qui
va réduire la capacité de l'union à agir
vite et puis à fortiori on va pas décidé
ce soir de mettre en place une armée
européenne
mais après pour rester humble aussi on
n'est qu'au début de cette guerre et on
ne sait pas du tout comment ça va
évoluer et peut-être que le conseil
européen va prendre des décisions
beaucoup plus audacieuse dans les jours
ou les semaines qui viennent justement
marc talent de cédric sur les évolutions
possibles qui s'offrent aujourd'hui à
l'union européenne alors vincent cours
on dit qu'on n'ira pas jusqu'à cette
armée européenne qui est un vieux rêve
européen on en parlera tout à l'heure
avec notre autre invité c'est un vieux
rêve de jean monnet de créer une armée
européenne
quelles sont les évolutions possibles
aujourd'hui c'est de réarmer
l'union européenne de renforcer
peut-être la collaboration entre les
vingt-sept armée de l'union européenne
alors oui n'oublions pas aujourd'hui que
la france est à une grande mais c'est
l'un des états membres qui a l'armé la
plus conséquente en la matière donc je
pense qu'il faut poser véritablement
toutes les conséquences qui pourrait y
avoir à traduire tout cela dans une
espèce de défense européenne qui de mon
point de vue n'est pas tout à fait à
l'ordre du jour puisque nous savons bien
que chaque état en a pas la même
approche en réalité de ce que doit être
une armée européenne
entend encore faudrait-il véritablement
que ce projet là parce que ça ne peut
pas s'improviser uniquement autour d'une
guerre qui hélas est à nos portes qui se
passe sur notre continent
prendre une décision d'une telle
envergure nécessitera un certain nombre
des changes et je ne crois pas
personnellement que ce soit tout à fait
à l'ordre du jour de créer une défense
européenne en tout cas pas au sens d'une
armée comme nous pouvons en avoir une en
france alors à l'ordre du jour justement
une autre question importante sur la
table c'est celle de la dépendance
énergétique l'union européenne est
dépendante des importations de gaz russe
à hauteur de 40% avec des disparités
selon les pays une dépendance vis-à-vis
aussi du pétrole on est obligé de
constater la hausse à la pompe a de plus
de 10 centimes d'euro s qui à votre avis
sur sur ce sujet c'est sur ce sujet
qu'on va voir si l'unité européenne
tient sur sur ce sommet européen oui je
crois que on a déjà montré que l'union
européenne finalement est assez
solidaire en ce moment y compris sur une
thématique de ce genre là puisque vous
l'avez très bien rappelé globalement on
voit que il y a des rapports de force la
france est un tout petit peu moins
dépendante de l'énergie russe que ce
soit le gaz ou le pétrole mais malgré
tout il va falloir retrouver en fait d
équilibre on voit que les sanctions ont
été votées par l'ensemble des états donc
avec un certain nombre de je dirais de
subtilité des états mais qu'ils sont pas
membres en réalité de l'union européenne
mais cette solidarité européenne en
réalité c'est consolider autour de ce
conflit ukrainien donc moi je pense que
nous allons pouvoir trouver des accords
autour d'une démarche commune tous
ensemble en tout cas c'est mon souhait
parce qu'il sera fondamental qu'après
cette solidarité aussi puis jouer entre
les différents états puisque nous
dépendance à l'énergie fournie par la
russie ne sont pas tout à fait les mêmes
je précise qu'il y aura sur la table la
mise en place d'un plan ripaud were eux
qui est l'idée c'est de l'énergie et
l'europe pour sortir progressivement de
cette dépendance aux énergies fossiles
russe une dernière question sur la table
si vincent couronne c'est l'adhésion de
l'ukraine un dossier épineux on imagine
bien le président volodymyr zelensky à
demander une adhésion sans délai demande
d'adhésion également exprimées par
d'autres pays par la suite la géorgie et
la moldavie qui craignent d'être les
prochains dans le viseur de la russie 1
qui ont déjà été amputée de région le
cédant 1 dans un passé récent est il
possible aujourd'hui de voir une
adhésion rapide de l'ukraine et aussi de
la géorgie et de la moldavie
techniquement oui d'un point de vue
strictement juridique on peut tout à
fait intégrer très rapidement elle est
un manque dans l'union européenne il ya
des critères à respecter mais cela en
fait peuvent être très facilement
modifiée par le conseil européen qui se
réunit d'ailleurs d'ailleurs ce soir en
pratique non en réalité un faux être
aussi réaliste
l'économie de l'ukraine et une économie
qui nécessite qu'elle n'en rattrapage
assez important pour pouvoir adhérer à
l'union européenne le salaire moyen en
ukraine c'est à peu près de 280 300
euros par mois c'est dix fois moins que
le salaire moyen de l'amour d'aidé
européen et puis il ya autre chose aussi
c'est que adhérer à l'union européenne
s'est aussi adhérer à sa politique de
défense et notamment adhérer un article
dans le traité sur l'union européenne
quels articles 42 paragraphe 16 ça cet
article là je ne fais pas de technique
mais c'est l'équivalent de l'article 5
de l'otan sur cette fameuse défense
mutuelle ou si un état est attaqué et
appelle à l'aide les autres doivent
faire le maximum pour l'aider
militairement et donc vous imaginez que
si l'union européenne en guerre adhérer
à l'union européenne ça nécessiterait
que les autres états membres de l'union
européenne se retrouvaient en guerre
face à la russie ce qu'elle a évidemment
personne ne veut ou ne peut se permettre
est-ce qu'on peut mettre une clause il
me semble il ya une clause qui est
possible peut-être pour éviter justement
ce dont vous parliez oui il est possible
d'avoir un de ménager un opt-out le
danemark par exemple à ce genre
d'obstacles sur sa politique de défense
mais il faut pas se leurrer même si le
danemark un opt-out sur ça si demain la
russie envahissait le danemark
évidemment que les européens réagir est
beau de manière beaucoup plus
massive et réactive qu'ils ne le font
ils à vis de l'ukraine aujourd'hui être
membre de l'union européenne ce n'est
pas simplement qu'un club économique
c'est un c'est une communauté de vue de
valeur qui fait qu'on se protège il ya
une solidarité européenne et et cette
dernière derniers mois avec le co vide
aussi l'ont bien montré donc c'est une
responsabilité que les états membres à
l'unanimité aujourd'hui ne sont pas
prêts à assumer
partager c'est vrai que vous vouliez
intervenir sur ce sujet parce que je
croise pour compléter les propos qui
vient d'être dit n'oublions pas aussi l'
équilibre globaux sur le continent
européen dans l'eau sur le continent
europe 1 nous avons toute une région qui
se sont les balkans occidentaux il se
trouve que je préside le groupe d'amitié
au sénat de cette région là et
aujourd'hui il faut que nous regardions
avec beaucoup d'attention tout à l'heure
que lorsque je parlais que nous devrions
être solidaire à la fois sur les
sanctions mais aussi sur la démarche à
suivre on voit bien que les balcons une
position un peu plus différente car très
dépendant pour le coût de l'énergie
russe et n'ouvrons pas une boîte de
pandore qui à un moment donné ferait que
tous ces états qui pour certains d'entre
eux je pense notamment à la macédoine du
nord d'ailleurs j'écris au président
macron dans ce sens là sont très
avancées ont entendu beaucoup d'années
et nous n'avons pas encore ouvert
véritablement la porte de l'union les
ppte et les états baltes aussi amour une
autre petite parenthèse ont attendu neuf
ans donc on ne peut pas à un moment
donné envoyer des messages qui pourrait
par moments paraître contradictoire et
ne fragile fragilisons pas des zones du
continent européen qui souhaite adhérer
à l'union européenne et qui en fait font
énormément d'efforts depuis des années
donc je pense qu'il faut que nous soyons
très prudent sur la position que nous
aurons vis-à-vis de l'ukraine dans sa
demande expresse un dernier tour de
parole martin décidera qui évince en
cours on va commencer avec vincent
couronne est ce que c'est un sommet à
votre avis qui peut réellement changé la
donne est ce qu'on peut s'attendre à de
grands changements avec ce sommet
bon alors c'est difficile à dire parce
que comme les européens se prononce à
l'unanimité dans ce genre de cénacles
d'institutions on n'est pas à l'abri que
1 et à la hongrie peut-être quelques
étapes bloc sur certains sujets en
revanche les symboles sont posées c'est
un conseil européen qui a eu à
versailles à vous même endroit où
emmanuel macron il ya cinq ans avait
reçu vladimir poutine on est dans une
crise majeure qui est équivalente
peut-être même encore plus important que
beaucoup plus grave que celle du co vide
à laquelle l'europe a été confrontée il
ya deux ans et donc on ne peut pas
imaginer que ce conseil européen si vous
voulez même d'un point de vue symbolique
ne sortent pas avec des décisions
historiques mais reçoit du cidre avec le
mot de la fin alors écoutez moi je ne
sais pas je ne peux pas préjuger de ce
qui en sortira de ce sommet n'oublions
pas qu'il s'inscrit malgré tout dans le
calendrier de la présidence française
donc c'était un sommet qui de toute
façon à les avoir lieu à un moment donné
la l'ukraine nous rattrape avec les
actualités terrible que vit cette ce
territoire de l'europe enfin du
continent européen donc soyons vigilants
soyons attentifs espérons une solidarité
européenne la plus large possible merci
martha de sidrac d'être venu en plateau
je rappelle sénatrice les républicains
des yvelines secrétaire de la commission
ait des affaires européennes au sénat il
vous est également la présidente de la
maison de l'europe des yvelines on peut
retrouver d'ailleurs un toutes les
informations sur la maison de l'europe
et via le lien qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran et merci à vincent couronne
d'avoir été avec nous par
visioconférence je le rappelle docteur
en droit public et fondateur du
collectif des surligneurs les
surligneurs qui interviennent
régulièrement sur tv 78 à retrouver tous
les vendredis dans l'émission 7 8
week-end et toutes les informations
aussi à retrouver sur le lien qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran
avec le sommet de versailles le secteur
autour du château est bouclé les abords
du site sont répartis en trois zones de
restriction pour la circulation des
véhicules et des piétons et de quoi
bouleverser quelque peu la vie des
versaillais pendant deux jours le
reportage à ce sujet de ces liga de son
go nickel et demi d'euros et nicolas
landry déviation c'est le mot du jour
pour les automobilistes versaillais la
cité royale accueille le sommet européen
au château de versailles un dispositif
de grande ampleur avec plus de 500
policiers gendarmes et crs le dispositif
décidé et mis en place par un contrôle
de zones de plusieurs zones périmétrique
autour du château est en place donc une
zone complètement étanche dans le
château et des zones à accès est réservé
un peu plus loin autour du château ainsi
que le dispositif de circulation qui
permettra d'accueillir l'ensemble des
délégations participant au sommet pour
les versailles est difficile parfois de
s'y retrouver certains ont eu des
difficultés de circulation le petit
périple aujourd'hui c'est que on
attendait le bus pour aller de la gare
rive droite à la
à la gare rive gauche et du coup on a
attendu le bus un quart d'heure on est
montés dans le bus et l'arrêt suivant
c'était le terminus est bien donc on est
obligé de faire toute la route à pied
avec un petit garçon qu'à trois ans
c'est pas facile j'ai pris le bus donc à
montigny qui aurait donc un grand
crochet qui a donc qui n'est pas du tout
passé par les arts est donc prévu et qui
a fait presque indirects enfin jusqu'à
la gare il gauche voilà non je vais
m'adapter et puis j'aime pas les vins
versailles et tant pis je ferais château
à nos jours je dois aller faire une
visite la clinique des franciscaines il
fallait que je me déplace du boulevard
de la reine franciscaine c'est
exactement le poser voilà non mais ça va
ils sont pas qu'on est habitué c'est pas
le premier le premier sommet un les
points d'accès au périmètre sont
nombreux cela concerne entre autres
l'entrée de la ville sur la rd 10 depuis
saint cyr l'école les rues de satory et
de l'orangerie ainsi que la venue de
saint cloud et la rue carnot les
versaillais avait été prévenue par
flyers dans les boîtes aux lettres
finalement la circulation pour les
piétons est plus simple que pour celle
des automobilistes pour le braquage
importe si terrible que ça parce que
pour finir on a été bien prévenu cela
était bien organisé depuis ses romans
que le tour du champion qui est pris au
reste de la ville est accessible donc
aucun problème particulier ça se fait
très bien oui effectivement ça va a été
prévenu on avait reçu des courriels
de la mairie de versailles donc j'avais
anticipé les choses en me garant dans
une rue qui n'étaient pas bloqués donc
voilà donc pour moi c'est pas très
contraignant finalement côté commerçants
dans la zone rouge interdite aux piétons
et voitures ce restaurant a décidé de
resté ouvert malgré tout on pense qu'on
va travailler avec le chauffeur les
garde côtes c'est normal que ça soit
fermé pause pour la sécurité des gens
dans la zone orange beaucoup de
commerces sont ouverts c'est le cas des
potences angela alors ça c'est la mairie
qui a déposé dans les boîtes aux lettres
de versailles avec toutes les
indications des zones rouges et oranges
donc nous on fait partie de la zone
orange donc on savait qu'on pouvait pas
stationner qu'on peut pas mettre les
poubelles dehors et qu'on peut pas faire
beaucoup de choses donc on ouvre ça on a
envie moi c'est ma première fois donc
comme je ne savais pas si j'allais
travailler ou pas et va j'ai ouvert j'ai
pas fait plus j'ai pas fait moins que
d'habitude les clients sont au rendez
vous autre information la gare de
versailles château rive gauche est
fermée jusqu'à vendredi 11 mars 18h fin
du dispositif entier également vendredi
soir une cellule d'information du public
avec une ligne téléphonique dédiée est
aussi ouverte édition spéciale consacrée
au sommet européen qui se tient à
versailles s'est ouvert ce jeudi et se
tient jusqu'à vendredi et j'accueille à
présent mon troisième invité dans cette
édition spéciale henri malot ce bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes le président de
l'association de la maison jean monnet
qui est basée à bazoches sur guyonne et
qui a pour mission de transmettre la
mémoire et l'héritage de jean monnet à
celui qui est considéré comme l'un des
pères fondateurs de l'europe ce qui est
intéressant quand on regarde les
thématiques de ce sommet de versailles
l'indépendance énergétique l'europe de
la défense ça renvoie au début
finalement de la construction européenne
dans les années 1950 si on prend déjà
rien que sur la la coc à la ceca la
communauté européenne du charbon et de
l'acier qui a été créée on le rappelle
en avril 1951 avec la signature du
traité de paris par six pays dont on
parlait déjà de la notion d'acier
finalement de charbon pardon je voulais
évoquer avec vous le charbon donc on
évoquait déjà la question énergétique
finalement
bonsoir donc d'abord jean monnet les pas
censé être il est le père de la
construction européenne avec avec robert
schuman à des combats navals à d'autres
puisque c'est jean monnet qui a rédigé
la fameuse déclaration schuman du 9 mai
1950 alors effectivement la communauté
économique charbon acier c'était surtout
ce qui était à l'époque le maire de la
guerre charbon est là si on a je volais
on à communautariser par contre ce qui
est le plus d'importance et de rappeler
qu'en 1954 jean monnet chemin et les
autres ont proposé une communauté
européenne de la défense oui et ce qui
est de ce projet avait été accepté en
serait pas là où on en est aujourd'hui
malheureusement c'est le parlement
français avec les voix des députés
gaullistes et des députés communistes
qui a rejeté ce projet donc
effectivement
jean monnet et les autres pères
fondateurs aurait bien voulu que
l'europe est une défense commune dès
1954 mais comme j'ai dit c'est la france
câble optez donc nous verrons que la
france par un petit peu ce se rattraper
j'aurais simplement signalé parce que
moi je me suis dit son président du lest
sur belle je participais à des sommets
européens et sommet européen ne sont pas
les mieux on décide pas de décision
d'édition il y aura une déclaration
commune cette déclaration va donner des
orientations
donc il faudrait éviter de désorienter
aux auditeurs ou téléspectateurs
téléspectateurs 10 mo 10 q mais les
souvenirs reviennent sont pas là pour
décider danse / pmi sont la promener les
orientations et juste pour préciser où
mais peut-être malentendu je n'ai pas
dit les sens et être père fondateur
l'européenne de l'union européenne de la
construction européenne j'ai bien dit il
est considéré comme l'un des pères
fondateurs de l'europe un jeu reprend
les mots qui sont sur votre site publié
sur le site de la maison jean monnet
vous le disiez très vite dans les années
1950 on évoque ce projet de au delà de
la défense à vous parliez tout à l'heure
de cette communauté européenne de la
défense juste rappeler le contexte de
l'époque pourquoi il ya cette idée très
vite qui n'est dans la tête de jean mais
ce qu'il en est le précurseur de cette
europe de la défense on pense forcément
au contexte tendu de la guerre froide
dans ces années 50 oui oui oui mais
aussi c'était aussi on était encore dans
la réconciliation
donc dans ce projet une communauté
européenne de la défense il y avait du
talent mais la manne qui était qui avait
été quelques années avant nos
adversaires et quel adversaire donc
c'était aussi dans l'idée de je dirais
de d'associer l'allemagne et l'italie
des anciens belligérants des anciens
adversaires dans un système de défense
commune qui n'était pas l'otan l'otan
donc
c'est un c'est l'alliance atlantique
avec les états unis l'union européenne
et la communauté européenne écho gâté
européenne de défense c'est autre chose
et je crois que le gros enjeux de ce
sommet en fait et comme je disais basse
un moment donné des orientations
c'est sa voix est ce qu'on veut comme
souhaite par exemple des polonais comme
souhaitent les pays d'europe centrale et
orientale simplement que la défense des
européens soit assuré par l'otan est
assuré c'est à dire par sylvie l'otan ce
sont des etats-unis où est ce qu'on veut
avoir une défense européenne
indépendante battu la pensée pour le
moment relativement isolé je dirais
malheureusement et si on l'avait journée
à 1954 voyez c'est pas
la veille c'est pas fière parce que en
fait l'année demain death punch mais ce
qui on avait des 1950 car si la france
n'avait pas bloqué cette communauté
européenne de défense on n'en serait pas
là
on est où la compétition française
d'avoir une défense européenne
indépendante de l'odeur est pour le
moment minoritaire mais c'est finalement
un projet bon qui fait parler encore de
lui un plus de soixante dix ans après sa
première évocation si on vient justement
sur le projet de communauté européenne
de la défense qu'est ce qu'il contenait
finalement il y avait la création
c'était évoqué la de l'armée européenne
à l'époque d'une armée européenne était
un petit peu sur le même sol même sur la
même méthode que celle avec laquelle on
a fait du charbon acier et
le marché commun c'est une méthode
progressive
je rappelle qu'il n'y a pas de
souveraineté européenne aujourd'hui sur
leurs intérêts dans des nations mais les
nations les états décident librement
sans souveraine de transférer une part
de leur souveraineté vers les niveaux
européens c'est ce qu'on a fait pour le
charbon et l'acier ce qu'on a fait pour
les affaires économiques c'est ce qu'on
a fait plus récemment pour amener avec
avec la mode et toute la communauté hop
et de défense était le transfert
progressif
des souverainetés des états en matière
de défense vers le niveau européen on
voit bien qu'aujourd'hui cela
s'imposerait car c'est ridicule que
bruxelles s'occupe dans la taille des
cornichons ou des ou des boîtes de
conserves de sardines et que par contre
dans ce domaine crucial qui est notre
d'entre indépendance et bien chaque état
et ses propres ses propres politiques
ses propres armes et avec en fait très
peu de coordination mais comme comme je
l'expliquais du fait que l'europe a
traîné à s'occuper de ces questions des
défenses depuis maintenant 67 ans c'est
à dire depuis le projet de la communauté
rockets de défense tiens tiens échoué
quand on n'a pas progressé pour un peu
est rentré dans l'idée notamment des ex
pays socialistes que le seul outil de
dépenses c'était le temps c'est pour
cela d'ailleurs que c'est très important
président ukrainien d'hélène ce qui a
vous avez sûrement entendu dans les
jours
c'est à renoncer à l'idée est ce que tu
prennes rejoindre l'otan qui était la
grande inquiétude de la russie la
demande peur la grande les prétextes ou
la raison de l'invasion mais a demandé à
rejoindre l'union européenne c'était
très différent rejoindre l'union
européenne s'est pas rejoindre l'otan
comme la fidi derrière très bien donc il
ya six pays membres de l'union
européenne sont les pays hôtes ils ne
sont pas dans le temps donc ça montre
bien que c'est aussi cette demande
d'adhésion du président kaczynski qu'il
est verni européenne travers le temps
c'est aussi un appel vers une défense
européenne indépendante
du logement il toute dernière session à
la noce et vous gagnez finalement c'est
un
an une toute dernière question vous le
disais ça un projet finalement qui va
être rejetée par l'assemblée nationale
en août 1954 comment peut-on expliquer
les réticences de l'époque quelle est
elle
je pense qu'il y avait le réticences le
parti communiste est évident parce que
tiko mais surtout en 1954 est totalement
inféodée à moscou donc toute défense
défense européenne était vu comme comme
hostile à l'urss et quant aux quant au
parti gaulliste
c'était surtout une façon de s'opposer à
la majorité des humains
socialistes centristes à l'époque plutôt
que plutôt qu'autre chose mais on voit
que ça a été une démarche extrêmement
malheureuse et cette alliance qui s'est
produit en 1954 et bien nous en payons
encore aujourd'hui malheureusement le
des résultats le prix est à prix très
près d'elle merci henri malosse est
revenu pour nous sur ce projet qui a été
ensuite abandonnés celui d'une
communauté européenne de la france et
pour la maison jean monnet qui
permettait qui est dans votre beau
département des yvelines et j'en ai tout
ce qu'est la visite peuvent retrouver
l'âme l'esprit de jean grenet la
création de murs et vous allez site
internet qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
pour retrouver toutes les informations
sur cette maison jean monnet le rappel
basée à bazoches sur guyonne merci henry
malouda var est avec nous et on continue
de scruter l'histoire avec mélanie poker
la rédaction de tv 78e arrogeant plateau
bonsoir mais là n'est ce pas avec ce
sommet européen qui se déroule on l'a
dit dans le cadre du château de
versailles c'est un lieu symbolique pour
les questions diplomatiques françaises
et européennes et oui l un des invités
est là a dit l'histoire fait parfois un
petit peu ironie le dernier chef d'état
reçu par emmanuel macron domaine royal
cette menace et vladimir poutine c'était
le 29 mai 2010 est emmanuel macron et à
leur président depuis quelques semaines
à l'accueil organisait pour évoquer
entre autres la lutte contre le
terrorisme les crises en syrie et en
ukraine une rencontre en petit comité
suivi d'un déjeuner avant de visiter une
exposition consacrée à pierre le grand
ça en 1717 le château de versailles est
un lieu diplomatique prisé par le chef
d'état français en 2018 emmanuel macron
il reçoit naruhito le prince héritier du
japon mais le domaine royal s'inscrit
également dans l'histoire française et
oui napoléon 1er et invite la reine de
westphalie en 1807 napoléon iii la reine
victoria en 1855
le maréchal de mme hackmann le shah de
perse en 1873 tsar nicolas ii est reçu
par félix faure en 1896 je vois un petit
historique s'être un peu long le général
de gaulle y organise lui onze rencontres
il y a eu celle avec nikita khrouchtchev
en 1960 ou encore richard nixon en 1969
plus récent françois mitterrand reçoit
lui le g7 en 1982 françois hollande
n'est pas en reste puisqu'il accueille
et le président chinois xi jingping en
2017 mais l'événement le plus connu
mélanie parce qu'il porte son nom c'est
au sortir de la première guerre mondiale
c'est le traité de versailles signe en
1919 et oui le 28 juin 1919 plus
exactement c'est le congrès de la paix
qui est organisée au sein même du
château l'allemagne est alors défaite en
1918 de nombreux chefs d'état y de
nombreuses délégations diplomatiques se
rassemblent autour de georges clemenceau
à leur président du conseil français et
le président des états unis woodrow
wilson robin il y avait l'idée de rendre
ne m'en plus
sûr par la démocratisation prix maman de
rendre le monde plus sûr par la sécurité
collective considération et 3
rendement peut-être plus interdépendants
il y avait déjà les dynamiques comme et
as face à lui en à clemenceau qui lui
il croit plutôt à la realpolitik
à la realpolitik redire aux rapports de
force dans louis estime bay durable bras
pose vraiment sur la force
françoise yves alors la signature du
traité aura lieu dans un endroit
emblématique du château la galerie des
glaces la délégation allemande arrive la
dernière mais c'est la première à signer
le document qui est installé sur un
bureau au ce milieu de la célèbre
galerie le château de versailles aura
aussi été le théâtre de plusieurs
congrès a depuis la réforme
constitutionnelle de 2008 les présidents
de la république ont la possibilité de
s'adresser au parlement le sénat et
l'assemblée nationale réunie au château
alors nicolas sarkozy lui dans fait
qu'un seul set en 2019 françois hollande
en 2019 pardon en 2007
françois hollande il rassemblera le
parlement suite aux attentats du 13
novembre 2015 emmanuel macron souhaite
en faire un rendez vous annuel en 2017
et 2018 il y renonce en 2010 cette fois
la date arrive il laisse son premier
ministre edouard philippe s'adresser aux
deux chambres directement dans les
chambres merci mélanie pour ce petit
point d'information autour de l'eau l'a
compris du château de versailles qui a
été théâtre déjà par le passé des deux
sommets internationaux oliel donc le
sommet européen qui se tient jusqu'à
demain vendredi et on peut le dire qui
est des as qui est déjà d'ores et déjà
historique pour la ville de versailles
signe de ce caractère exceptionnel le
nombre de journalistes accrédités sur
les deux jours de ce rendez-vous des
reporters venus du monde entier pour
suivre les échanges entre les 27 états
membres de l'union européenne est sur
place on retrouve nicolas landry et
michael et nuit d'euros
ils sont mille journalistes accrédités
pour les deux jours du sommet européen à
versailles danse et de tentes installées
sur la place d'armes juste devant le
château on retrouve principalement des
journalistes venus de l'union européenne
se situe à schoenau à la situation est
vraiment tendu elles concernent la
finlande à cause de notre frontière avec
la russie
je pense que la finlande espère que les
autres états membres exprimeront du
solidarité vis-à-vis des dents en termes
de sécurité nous ne sommes pas membres
de l'otan et donc l'union européenne est
vraiment très importante
quelques mètres plus loin une équipe de
la télévision allemande zdf au total
techniciens et journalistes compris ils
sont neuf à travailler sur ce sommet
l'idée de président marc rang qu'il a
eue d'une europe souveraine de temps en
temps les autres pays en même serions
tout petit peu n'ont pas trouvé cette
idée trop sérieuse mais maintenant ça
change on a vraiment en
vers une europe plus souveraine je pense
que ici à verser un peu voir les
premières pas dans ce chemin là un
sommet européen qui intéresse également
le monde entier cette correspondante
syrienne à paris assure des directs
toutes les heures pour une télévision du
moyen-orient amérique latine l'amérique
la russie la chine sont concernés donc
le moyen-orient aussi vous savez la
russie a aussi des militaires par
exemple en syrie
ce problème n'affecte pas uniquement les
relations entre l'amérique la russie et
l'europe mais aussi avec le moyen-orient
est affecté en sang mais de risque tous
attendent désormais les décisions qui
seront prises pendant ce sommet un
rendez-vous déjà historique versailles
n'avait plus accueilli autant de
journalistes depuis le dernier g7 en
voilà ce qu'on pouvait vous dire sur ce
sommet européen qui s'est ouvert à
versailles qui se tient jusqu'à demain
au château de versailles noms viendront
demain vendredi sur ce rendez vous dans
notre émission 7,8 week end une
information avant de vous laisser la
préfecture des yvelines annonce
l'ouverture d'une plateforme d'accueil
et des réfugiés ukrainien dans le
département le préfet jean-jacques brot
a missionné l'association aurore pour ce
faire la plateforme et téléphoniques
dans un premier temps et réservée aux
ressortissants ukrainiens présent dans
les yvelines aux collectivités et aux
associations
trois missions répondre aux
interrogations des réfugiés sur le
logement le droit au séjour les droits
sociaux la santé et la scolarisation à
parier les offres aux besoins de
logements sur le territoire pour les
communes et associations enfin assure
une coordination de tous les services la
plateforme est joignable de lundi à
vendredi au vendredi de 9h à 18h sur le
numéro bien sûr qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran voilà c'est la fin de cette
édition spéciale merci de nous avoir
suivis merci également aux équipes
techniques une édition à revoir sur
notre site internet et notre application
mobile belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]